some anomalies kill for fun others for
food others because they simply have no
choice on the other side of the coin
some want nothing more than to spread
love joy and happiness but it's rare
that you see an anomaly that has
genuinely pure intentions but his
attempts to do good often turn deadly
one such figure and the subject of
today's tale is
scp-049 the plague doctor if you're at
all familiar with the scp foundation
then you will have likely heard of the
infamous plague doctor for those of you
who haven't here's a bit of context for
scp-049 he appears exactly as you'd
expect a plague doctor from the late
medieval period or renaissance periods a
tall figure shrouded in long black robes
a hood over his head with only a
venetian beaked mask protruding from
underneath these aren't just a fashion
statement either the scp foundation
discovered that these are all part of
scp-049's physical body sharing a
similar structure to muscle and bone the
plague doctor's primary goal is to find
those he considers to be infected with
something he refers to as the pestilence
if he ever senses this affliction he
will attempt to make direct skin contact
with the person carrying it why because
scp-049's touch is lethal killing anyone
he comes into contact with you might
think that's all the plague doctor does
goes from person to person killing them
with his deadly touch but you would be
wrong once he's killed a victim
scp-049 then begins performing a crude
outdated form of surgery on their corpse
using equipment he produces from his
mysterious and apparently bottomless
magical medical satchel he injects a
number of unknown chemicals into the
corpse which brings them back to life
and turns them into an instance of
scp-049-2
in other words a vicious mindless zombie
at present scp-049 is kept secure in a
holding cell by the foundation under
watched by surveillance cameras for 24
hours a day and that is where our story
begins the tale of a deadly dangerous
doctor and his days spent in captivity
locked away in a cage contained by the
scp foundation there he sits alone it is
a tale known only by the simple title
going home it begins with the plague
doctor left alone in his cell he had
been there for such a long time that
he'd forgotten exactly how long but
there he sat taunted by the sensation of
pestilence around him it was a small
almost undetectable feeling but it
reeked of decay and disease hanging in
the very air particles of scp-049
cell although they have long since
stopped the practice the scp foundation
used to send its doctors and researchers
into zero four nines cell bringing him
cadavers as test subjects the plague
doctor would use these specimens to hone
his craft perfecting his method of
transforming the dead into instances of
scp-049-2
but of course the doctors working for
the foundation weren't exactly free of
disease themselves and they too often
needed to be cured by his touch and soon
they stopped visiting scp-049 in person
leaving him alone in his cell even these
so-called people of science feared the
true cure it seemed they would talk to
the plague doctor via an intercom system
interviewing him and asking questions
about what he did or how he felt one
question stood out to scp-049
the foundation researchers had asked him
if he had any regrets for what he had
done to people the plague doctor thought
it foolish to even ask and then even the
questions coming through the intercom
stopped after a while for a time as
cp049 was happy in his cell left alone
with his thoughts safe from the diseases
of the outside world the blank doctor
was at peace for a change resting in
comfort until the familiar smell of
pestilence returned the presence of
disease drove him to attempt an escape
producing his medical implements from
his bag he kept concealed in his robes
scp-049 tried to pry open the door to
his cell he wasn't sure how long it took
the passage of time had long since
stopped registering to him but
eventually he had it open just enough so
that he could pass through out into the
corridor beyond the chamber that he had
been held in there was no one else
around no doctors or researchers or
foundation security personnel no one to
stop the plague doctor from following
the stench of the disease that had
driven him to find a way out of
containment navigating through the
hallways of the foundation facility
scp-049 tracked the source of the
disease to a locker with little trouble
he opened it finding a metallic box
within as he studied the container his
fingers found the button that opened it
it hissed as the gases kept the inside
of the box mixed with the air the cold
vapor hit the plague doctor in the face
catching him by surprise and making him
drop the box reasserting himself the
plague doctor bent over and picked up
the contents of the refrigerated
container a single mosquito it wasn't
the insect itself that had drawn
scp-049 out of his cell true mosquitoes
are known to spread diseases like
malaria but it was what was inside this
mosquito that the doctor wanted to
eradicate its blood sac was full swollen
with dark fluid that scp-049 knew to be
infected using the metal box is an
improvised operating table he produced
his bag of medical implements and the
doctor began to operate he retrieved a
syringe from his bag and a vial filled
with thick black liquid half filling the
syringe with the liquid he plunged the
needle into the mosquito and extracted
the blood that the insect was carrying
the infected bodily fluid mixed with the
medicine in the doctor's syringe leaving
the bug as little more than a dry husk
the plague doctor watched as the two
substances mixed together before
stabbing back into the mosquito filling
the creature with a combination of both
liquids he refused to leave any trace of
pestilence in the insect's body the
mosquito twitched itself back to life
looking around until it saw scp-049
observing it who's there it asked
where's merley there is no one here but
me and you the doctor explained you are
in a prison though the wardens it seems
have left a prison the insect responded
oh god i'm at site 19. naturally it
seemed rather strange for a mosquito to
be able to talk let alone know about the
highly classified site-19 but as is
always the case in the scp foundation
the strange always has an anomalous
explanation you see this mosquito was
not like any other for one she even had
a name it was leslie as it turned out
leslie was part of an scp one of the
foundation's own creation scp-3774
these were a genetically and
cybernetically enhanced species of
mosquito why would the foundation spend
time and resources creating something
like this originally they were designed
as an undetectable covert way of keeping
tabs on persons of interest to the scp
foundation the plague doctor thought it
odd that after having spent so much time
in prison there that he should finally
learn the name of site 19 from a
mosquito of all things leslie seemed to
be in a state of panic however urgently
insisting that she had to get back to
someone named merly as cp049 had no clue
what she meant he'd never encountered
anyone that went by that name and had no
idea where to even begin looking i know
where he lives i can find it the
mosquito insisted i just i don't know
how i could ever get out of here she was
wary of the creature she found herself
talking to despite being a genetically
engineered insect leslie was for all
intents and purposes an agent of the scp
foundation and now she was currently
conversing with an anomaly that she knew
nothing about but he wasn't trying to
harm her in fact whatever the plague
doctor had done seemed to have revived
her i have gotten myself this far and
now that i have i have no further reason
to stay here the doctor announced
holding a handout for leslie to fly up
to then then then you'll help me get out
of here she asked readying her wings and
landing in his palm i will
scp-049 agreed the pair introduced
themselves properly leslie giving
scp-049 her name while he just
instructed her to call him doctor before
they set out together after almost a
week of traveling on foot through rugged
terrain and harsh winds the plague
doctor and his insect companion had yet
to encounter another living soul thick
dark clouds hung in the sky above them
and leslie soon found it hard to
remember what the sun looked like she
feared that she might even forget
merlie's face we're close she said just
a few more miles and then and then we
will arrive
scp-049 finished her sentence tell me
doctor why did you come all this way
with me leslie the mosquito asked you
could have left when we got out gone on
your own way in response he gave one
simple sentence merely because i wanted
to
finally the intrepid pair arrived at a
house once belonging to merle it was
abandoned ramshackle in a total state of
disrepair decades had passed since
anyone had set foot in the place the
living room that had once been so
familiar to leslie had now been
transformed into a barren empty space
the sight of it made her so distraught
with sadness that she would have been
sick if mosquitoes could be sick merlay
whoever he was or had been was now
nowhere to be found one of leslie's
cybernetic enhancements was an internal
positioning system giving her all sorts
of data and readouts including a clock
it told her just how long she'd been
away for i've been dead for 200 years
the mosquito cried in the palm of the
doctor's hand then when merle is is dead
everyone everyone is dead she kept
repeating it to herself over and over as
if she was trying to convince herself of
what had happened eventually the words
lost all meaning as he held leslie in
his hands perhaps the plague doctor felt
sorry for the mosquito after all the
plague doctor had always had a
respectful polite personality despite
his frightening exterior he had always
believed that he'd acted in service of
the greater good trying to cure the
world of pestilence to bring the end of
disease he only ever killed because to
him it was in his victim's best interest
for him to perform his procedures to his
captors at the scp foundation the doctor
had been courteous and cooperative and
he acted the same towards his fellow
scps not just leslie but even the sort
of anomalies with nothing but hatred in
their hearts the doctors saw them as
just further victims of the pestilence
in need of curing
scp-049 sat in silence for a while with
his mosquito friend letting her mourn
the loss of merle and everything she had
ever known where will you go now he
asked still in tears barely able to
speak through her sobs leslie decided
that she wanted to stay where she was
the insect wanted to live where merle
had lived in a desperate attempt to
recapture the world that she once knew
sitting in the plague doctor's gloved
hands still sobbing even though she had
run out of tears leslie said
any minute any minute merlie will come
through the door the plague doctor held
his tiny companion where she was while
she grieved then i would wait for him he
told her here with you now go check out
scp-049 the plague doctor captured and
scp-049 what actually is the pestilence
the plague doctor questions and theories
for more on this enigmatic medicine man